isn't just republicans coming after joe
biden's student debt forgiveness plan
the day it was announced former obama
economic advisor trashed the plan as
pouring gasoline on the already rampant
inflation issue
yesterday longtime democrat advisor paul
begala was even more withering in his
criticism
for that amount of money you could fund
free pre-k for every three and
four-year-old for ten years you do a lot
more good for poor people communities of
color and and the underprivileged by
doing pre-k
you could forgive all medical debt which
unlike student debt is not freely
entered into
so
democrats i'm i'm a progressive i want
to help folks but i think this is
terrible policy so what is my party
doing with this they're they're they're
disadvantaging i think they're not
helping the people that we're here to
help which is poor people
and and underprivileged communities and
they're not helping their politicians
who are running
yikes
i agree with paul bagala she's smart
right on here now former secretary of
education under donald trump betsy devos
so betsy what's your take on on this
loan forgiveness plan what impact is it
going to have per you know your time and
expertise on education
well sean first of all it's 100 illegal
right the president has no authority to
just wave a magic wand and suddenly
forgive billions and billions of dollars
in student loan debt congress has the
power of the purse not the president
secondly it is totally unfair to all of
those who have not taken out student
loans two out of three americans who
have not attended a four-year college or
university and for those students who
faithfully been paying their student
loans down
how does that work for them
not to mention the veterans who have
earned
their tuition and earned the privilege
of attending higher education because of
their service
it is fundamentally unfair
it is wrong
and not only that but it doesn't solve
any problem
all it does is mean a political payoff
to voters that biden and his
administration hope to attract in
november listen
it's a payoff to the teachers colleges
and to universities that are
indoctrinating our kids they're turning
them out into little activists little
democrat voters so why won't the
democrats say you know what we're going
to forgive debt so universities can
charge our kids even more money and they
can make more money
well and here's and there's there's the
thing that you know stu since the
federal government took over all of
student lending
the costs for higher education have
continued to skyrocket
multiple times the rate of inflation
multiple times and there is no
accountability there's no governor on
that for higher ed institutions they can
get just continue to charge more and
more they have nothing on the hook
they're getting the money whether the
student is successful or not whether the
student pays back his or her loans or
not and so it's a system that was built
on a
a failing foundation to begin with
so the solution is not to just forgive a
bunch of debt it's to really go look at
the problem and get to the root of it
and change things you know betsy the
issue i think is if you make the
universities
uh responsible for the debt that kids
can't pay back guess what universities
are going to get a lot cheaper thanks
for joining me i appreciate it hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else